et on va parler de course à pied on le
disait avec nos invités avec Nicolas
Landry qui est toujours avec moi en
plateau ce dimanche c'est le 41e cross
de la sablière c'est à partir de 9h30 du
côté de la commune de Viroflay au
programme des courses pour les enfants
ainsi que le maître à 11 km et il y a
une course pour les enfants il y a
également à 6 km et 11 km voilà donc
trois courses au programme et pour nous
en parler je le disais on le disais tout
à l'heure il y a deux invités avec nous
en plateau Jean-Pierre Rouyer qui est le
président de l'USM Viroflay qui a
organisé bien sûr ce cross de la
sablière et également Alan brachelet
Brachet pardon un triathlète de de 25
ans on le disait tout à l'heure tout est
prêt à quelques jours de l'événement là
on est dans les starting blocks il y a 4
course enfant et pas une mais une course
crosse-cour une course cross long en
supplément forcément donc 4 course
enfant oui un 6 km 11 km voilà c'est ça
pour les adultes donc à partir de 9h30
pour les plus petits dimanche matin et
ben je trouve toute la matinée donc
aujourd'hui et ce soir on est à 700
inscrits déjà inscrits en ligne on peut
encore offrir jusqu'à jeudi soir en
ligne et après vendredi samedi
éventuellement dimanche au siège du club
ou sur place directement dimanche matin
un quart d'heure avant le début de la
course sachant qu'il vaut mieux s'y
prendre un poêle à l'avance parce que il
y aura je pense beaucoup de monde on
essaye cette année de battre les 1100
participants on était à 1086 l'année
dernière on essaiera de battre ce record
cette année sachant que je pense qu'il
va faire beau froid mais très beau et le
parcours n'est pas trop trop beau donc
je pense que tout est tout est en place
pour que ça fasse une bonne une bonne
course dimanche et de bonnes
performances pour tout le monde tous les
voyants sont ouverts Nicolas alors
justement vous parlez il va peut-être on
annonce des températures assez froides
comment on se prépare face à la
fraîcheur Alan sachant que voilà c'est
on est toujours en hiver et forcément il
faut habituer le corps à cette
température du coup pour se préparer ce
qu'il faut c'est un bon échauffement
donc peut-être que l'échauffement il y
aura plus longtemps que si il fait chaud
donc réussir à chauffer peut-être pour
ceux qui vont faire le crosse court et
croissant 30 minutes au moins quand même
avant la course et si le corps est chaud
dès le départ il sera habitué et du coup
il y aura pas il y aura pas de problème
pendant la course nous disait tout à
l'heure Alan dans le calendrier il est
très bien placé cet événement tout à
fait là le week-end dernier c'était les
régions de cross donc le weekend
prochain il y a pas de compétition au
calendrier pas de cross
au niveau de la fédération en tout cas
et les LIFA donc les intérêts régionaux
la semaine d'après donc dans deux
semaines alors vous dites que le
parcours va pas être trop boueux
justement quel est-il ce parcours est-ce
que il y a il y a de l'altitude est-ce
que il y a une il y a une c'est un
parcours compliqué ou pas oui parce que
d'abord il entièrement boisé dans la
forêt de Meudon donc c'est aussi c'est
quand même assez rare et puis là aussi
occidenté parce que quand on monte de
Viroflay vers illicite tout ce qui
connaissent un petit peu de côté de
profs fontaine c'est quand même assez
assez pointu et il y a quand même de
sacré moment
comment a passé et
donc le cross le parcours je pense est
assez est assez varié et très
intéressant 41 édition comment on arrive
à se renouveler chaque année c'est
difficile pour un tas de raisons y
compris sur le plan du budget parce
qu'effectivement c'est plus en plus
coûteux et plus en plus difficile donc
connaissez un tel événement il faut
beaucoup d'accord la cornef la corde à
Croix Rouge la cour de la police les
accords municipaux il faut aussi
beaucoup de communication pour
effectivement pour attirer du monde
ça se fait pas comme ça donc c'est ben
c'est un travail de très longue haleine
très difficile et surtout le même jour
même il faut quand même au moins 60
bénévoles pour assurer l'événement en
plus des partenaires privés qui nous
aident sur la sécurité sur la santé sur
le chronomètre et également le les
services municipaux qui travaillent déjà
dans la semaine pour installer tout ce
qui va avec les barnums les tables et
chaises et puis forcément le parcours le
jour même c'est une grosse machine
est-ce qu'on peut dire qu'aujourd'hui
après 41 éditions ce sera la 41e ce
week-end c'est l'un des plus gros
événements la matière en Île-de-France
dans le département des Yvelines oui je
pense que oui parce qu'aujourd'hui il y
en a d'abord il y a moins de crottes qui
sont organisés d'abord en France en
Île-de-France qu'on te dit des
difficultés que je viens d'évoquer d'une
part et puis d'autre part ben comment
c'est de plus en plus compliqué parce
que je pense que c'est pas une machine
qui se met en place automatiquement
année après année c'est chaque année on
met carrément les compteurs à zéro pour
pour retrouver tout ce qu'il faut des
partenaires
un nouveau parcours
et tout tout relancer toutes les
machines par rapport à la communication
quel est votre objectif cette année vous
allez gagner l'année dernière en 2022
déjà avec quel chrono et puis peut-être
nous annoncer le chrono que vous visez
cette année si vous voulez pas dévoiler
trop d'informations
voilà on accepte mais voilà alors
Jean-Pierre c'est un peu emballé j'ai
fini trois gemmes l'année dernière
l'objectif de cette année c'est de faire
un meilleur chrono de 1 de 2 d'avoir des
meilleurs sensations et de trois mon
sera olifa parce que du coup j'ai fait
les régions de cross et je suis qualifié
au olifa donc l'objectif ce sera plutôt
olifa pour réussir à décrocher une
qualification pour les championnats de
France et pour se préparer pour être
mieux on imagine c'est un entraînement
toute l'année pour performer sur ce
genre de d'événement c'est un
entraînement alors oui c'est un
événement à l'année après ma préparation
elle se fait aussi pour l'été pour la
piste et je suis encore de 1500 et 800
depuis l'année dernière et je me suis
mis surtout à l'athlétisme depuis que je
travaille à Viroflay et donc la
préparation hivernale donc elles sont
partout de l'année effectivement mais
elle prépare aussi l'été une réaction
par rapport à ce que disait Jean-Pierre
sur les difficultés du parcours quels
sont-elles est-ce que vous êtes d'accord
et s'ils disaient sur les points un peu
difficiles de ce parcours oui il y a des
des endroits très exigeants donc même
dès le début ça monte assez raide après
avoir fait une montée assez raide ça
dure longtemps
il y a une grande partie de plats donc
c'est un peu un soulagement quand on
arrive sur le plat qui est assez longue
donc faut réussir à relancer il y a
adapter sa foulée pour pour réussir à
pas perdre de temps et en gagner même et
après c'est après c'est grandes parties
plats malheureusement il y a des
descentes et démonter avec beaucoup de
cailloux beaucoup de d'endroits où il
faut rester attentifs parce qu'on peut
se tord de la cheville facilement donc
voilà et donc quatre courses j'ai le bon
chiffre pour les enfants c'est à dire
que c'est aussi un événement assez
ouvert finalement qui qui le but aussi
de l'ouvrir à au plus grand nombre bien
sûr parce qu'il faut transmettre
effectivement vis-à-vis des plus jeunes
premièrement deuxièmement c'est un
événement familial il y a beaucoup de de
famille qui vont participer ensemble il
y a une famille dans la famille dugion
qui sont je crois cinq ou si inscrits il
y a tous les cousins les parents
peut-être même les grands-parents bon
moi je l'ai fait en 1978 mon fils l'a
fait plus tard et j'espère que ma petite
fille le fera bientôt donc sur Viroflay
c'est un événement parce que culturel
tout le monde connaît le cross et depuis
longtemps et ça fait partie au-delà de
la compétition humaine c'est un
certainement familial sur un dimanche
d'hiver ou en fin de compte ce sera la
fête du sport à Viroflay l'événement
familier aussi à la solidarité parce que
pour la bonne cause il y aura une
collecte de bouchons également qui sera
effectué parce qu'effectivement on
accepte les sportifs de handicap on les
accueille volontiers et cette année on
boit aussi un autre record il y aura 6
Golette de 3 clubs différents et d'une
de l'espoir des bouchons de l'espoir et
de fraternités qui est une un club de
Paris qui est effectivement aura aussi
une geolet et donc effectivement tout le
monde partira en même temps et tout le
monde participait au croisement je serai
la fête personne ne sera écartée très
rapidement 1100 participants l'année
prochaine vous l'avez dit au tout début
l'objectif c'est de faire plus c'est que
c'est faisable vous pensez faisable
c'est pas un objectif a priori comment
une obsession mais bon c'est pour pas
effectivement pour pour garder le pour
garder le le bon cap quoi c'est un peu
ça le l'idée bon après effectivement on
pourra on accueillir un peu plus mais
après au bout d'un moment il y a aussi
des dominations différentes il peut y
avoir des dangers notamment des
bousculades de départ des choses comme
ça donc c'est pour ça aussi qu'on a un
slip aujourd'hui organise plus de course
enfant pour éviter ce genre de problème
bien sûr toutes les informations sur le
site du cross de la sablière à retrouver
sur donc voilà vous voyez il est
s'affiche en bas de l'écran vous allez
le faire Nicolas vous êtes prêts non je
serai pas prêt je vais être un peu
compliqué en tout cas on retrouve toutes
les informations merci à vous deux
d'être passé en plateau pour en parler
je rappelle un 41e édition de ce cross
de la sablière ce dimanche à 9h30 c'est
à viro